each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so why don't we go ahead and get
started it's my pleasure today to
introduce Chris Coyle from the
University of Waterloo he'll be getting
his PhD very very soon now and chris is
a little bit different from many of the
speakers that we get here in this room
he comes from a school of management
sciences and has an organizational
Theory background but I can promise you
since he was our intern that he knows
how to speak ordinary English and talk
to geeks just fine it won't be all
technical babble fact probably would be
any techno babble from from organization
behavior and he's going to tell us today
about his research on coordination among
software development teams a topic that
is near and dear to our hearts so well
thank you very much for coming my name's
as Rob said Christopher Foyle University
of Waterloo department of management
sciences in the Faculty of Engineering
I've titled this talk the social
programmer so I'm starting from this
assumption there's been a very long time
since there was a loan program in his
own room who could produce commercial
quality software these days software
projects require almost every type of
organizational role and when we split
these tasks and two separate roles these
rules require coordination and
collaboration it's create a complex
problem because all these roles need to
communicate in order to get their job
done so this is what this talk is about
a coordination and software development
and how social and task forces influence
it so in this talk I'm going to be using
a concept called task structure and i'll
be using it throughout the talk so it's
good to just review what i mean by task
structure it means different things for
different people and so let's just
clarify what i mean by that
we have two people a and B and they both
have a task and for example one task
could feed into another so task a feeds
into task B that means task be as a
dependency on task a they use or consume
what task a produces now of course it
could go the other way task B could feed
into task a or it could be reciprocal so
we call that or task a and has be could
share resources so this is what I mean
when I say task structure is the
interrelationship between people and
their tasks as they're getting the work
done so what I'm specifically interested
in this talk is when one task feeds a
lot more into another task so when task
a feeds a lot of their output into task
B task B is said to have an asymmetric
dependency on task a so even if task B
feeds back into task a it's not the same
extent that task a feeds and task p so
that's called a symmetry and I'll be
focusing this talk on this kind of task
relationship an asymmetric toss
relationship so I'm going to just
briefly describe what the point of this
talk is so that we know where we're
going so this talk will show for things
one it shows that an asymmetry and
dependency will lead to a difference in
perceptions among the people involved
too it'll show an asymmetry and
dependency will lead to a difference in
behaviors and three it will show that an
asymmetry in dependency will lead to a
difference in expectations fourth I'm
going to describe how a person a worker
let's say a this worker is in what we
would call a work situation and there's
a field of forces both task forces and
social forces that are acting on him
that in some part in large part
determine the actions that he takes so
that's the the theoretical argument that
i'll be making that's point for so let's
start now so now that i'm showing where
we're going let's see how we get there
so we'll start with the story of Jane
Jane's a PM a program manager here at
Microsoft she's a she has a definite
asked to her
years and they form a feature Kurt now
Jane also interacts with a feature crew
on the same floor and she interacts with
that p.m. and not dev and Jane also
interacts with the future crew in
another building and she interacts with
their p.m. in their def Jane also
interacts with a future crew in India so
we have global software development
issues she interacts with their p.m. and
their dev now an interesting thing
happened while we were observing the
situation are a little bit before the
interviews this p.m. in India moved and
they moved to the other building so now
they're debonair test depend very
heavily on a p.m. that is not located
with them or even in the same country
Jane also interacts with the team from
Boston but their tests aren't embossed
in there in the same floor and Jane
interacts with their p.m. so this is
actually a quite simplified version of
what's really going on and we call this
Jane social network this is why I think
social sorry this is why I think
software is very interesting this is the
social p.m. this is the social Deb this
is the social test we now know through
previous research that software projects
are heavily influenced by social factors
in fact it's one of the founding
principles of the hip group it's about
people working together I'm going to
engage in a somewhat dangerous activity
here I'm going to try to graph previous
research and I'm creating a false
dichotomy of theoretical and practical
it just serves the purpose for this talk
and to situate my work in previous work
we tend to see that a lot of theoretical
work bunches up in this area and that's
a lot of management work and we see a
lot of the lot of practical work bunches
down and misc tends to be in this area
and that tends to be software
engineering related so my work falls a
little bit into both camps the exact
position of course doesn't matter and in
some cases was because I wanted to
clearly show the text so just the
important part is the area so my work
falls into both very practical as I'll
show you the interview methods and
observation methods that I've used in
the past and in the theoretical part as
I'll show with a field theory way of
looking at the situation so together I
hope when you combine my type of
research it'll lead to something
somewhere in the middle and I think my
goal is a researcher over time is just
to kind of fly off to the right
hopefully not too far so now that we
know where this is situated we have some
questions to ask about James situation
the basic question is how does jay and
get our work done and we can take a
social network approach and we see that
her task networks don't follow
organizational lines and they span
organization group boundaries and these
groups may have competing goals and
competing personal situations such that
their small groups goals don't really
contribute to the overall system so it's
it's a complex situation and what we
want to know is how to take a look at
this so one thing that's interesting is
that this analysis the social network
analysis misses a few things first it
doesn't tell us the specifics of the
interaction so we know that a and B
communicate with each other and we know
direction and in some cases the weight
from some analysis but we know that
communication does not equal
effectiveness or effective communication
and that's represented by green lines so
a helpful interaction between task and
task beat communication does not
necessarily mean that in fact in some
cases communication indicates that there
are unhelpful interactions between task
and task be I for each also what this
doesn't tell us is that for each task
there may be different networks of
interactions so for task one Jane may
have a certain pattern of interaction
with each have their own helpful and
unhelpful relations but her other task
may have a completely different
interaction pattern with their own
helpful and unhelpful pneus yes I'm
swimming the communication between a and
B is just you know verbal hallway
conversation one example of that then
that's true it would be the
communication between task a and Caspian
casts communicate so the question is is
there a difference I guess between
social communication and task
communication yeah I guess I'm trying
maybe I misunderstood this machine
working but the line between task and
has be man versus with wine so what I
mean by that is you can have a
communication between a person a and
person B but it's not necessarily
task-related communication so I
task-related communication would be the
lines between their tasks yeah so the
question is how do we get this data then
how do we turn how do we get this rather
complicated messy information and one
way to get that is through a social
observation and interview methods so
I'll give you some example interview
questions I've described this in the
paper that i just recently submitted so
we first asked Jane who do you interact
with in this task and so she says I
interact with these PM's in these dads
and I also interact with Boston in India
I also interact with an external group
and she interacts with a social
technical system products to do so in
this way we have social technical
interaction because as a lot of devs
will tell us in Microsoft products to do
significantly affects their task in
their ability to get their work done the
question that we ask is very specific
when you interact with this person can
you give specific examples of things
they do that help you get your job done
and then we asked the other specific
examples of things that don't help you
to complete your job so the interview
meth is actually quite simple but
extremely powerful
it gives us data that is that are
examples of actual behaviors and those
behaviors are significant and meaningful
to the participants the examples are
context-dependent situated in
ecologically valid and they avoid
ungrounded opinion and stereotype so
what we really want to get away from is
language language is really the killer
for any qualitative work whether it's
ethnographic or interview what we want
here are examples of things that
actually happened to Jane so jane says
that my boss is a good leader that's not
as useful as Jane saying my boss does
this and that's what helps me get my job
done so that's the kind of data we're
trying to get using this interview
method yes there is are the things that
they do that help you are going to help
you which that do seems to be asking for
stereotyping as opposed to in the last
week or in the one you know in the last
time period give me specific examples of
things that they did yes yes you're
exactly right so this is the
simplification of that actual question
when you form these questions in the
interview you ask with respect to a
specific task and within a specific time
period because time period will change a
person's social network their social
network on last month's tasks are going
to be possibly completely different from
two months before so you ask within this
time period and this task what did they
do that yeah you found helpful what did
they do exactly yeah that's a very good
point yeah avoiding minions stereotypes
because obviously things that may choose
are based on scare games for one thing
yes so there's no way to get away from
the fact that we perceive our situation
with our own biases and so you may
perceive somebody's doing something bad
to you that may not have actually
happened for example but what we want to
get our examples of things so we try to
get away from things that didn't really
affect their task and if they did
mention this then
in a way that's important to them and
that's what we want to pick up things
that have happened that they recognize
is important to them that's the data
that we want so in other words these
questions are specifically chosen to be
an attitudinal right it's not that
you're trying to get at you know you
weird as you know most of your
coordination time go right which you
might get with a stopwatch observation
or something right but you're actually
trying to get their attitudes about
coordination yeah yeah we this this
method recognizes that we are beings in
our own perceptual field and what we
perceive as important to us is is what
we want to pick up in this case using
the stopwatch method gets very good data
in its own right but what this tries to
kind of fix from that method is we see
somebody interacting say 45 minutes with
somebody in the hallway now we're not
exactly sure how that affected their
task we go and ask them how did that
interaction if I could ask well that
really wasn't task related or it was a
very small amount of impact whereas the
communication that may have taken a very
small amount of time very much impacted
their task yeah so there's definitely
there's you know benefits to every
method and hopefully by using multiple
methods that's where you really get the
good data you get triangulation
so this is just one part what I'm
presenting today is there's a small part
of what I've done in the past I've
worked observing object observing agile
software development in object mentor in
Chicago I've also been involved with a
very long-term project in Belle looking
at their new product development and
I've also done this study in microsoft
research over the past summer we did a
general study of coordination between
software teams we got around 400
behaviors from this I'm going to be
showing a very small portion of this
study which is equivalent to about 125
behaviors I won't be telling you all of
the behaviors of course I'll be telling
you so this is who we studied this group
grew from 20 to 300 people in two and
half years so extremely strong growth we
did 30 to 1 hour interviews to
equivalent to about 450 pages of text
and we interviewed for the purposes of
this when I'm presenting today 13 people
from a group called application and
seven people from a group called
platform application as the names imply
with we're building a customer-facing
portion of the product on top of
platforms code and that will become very
important later we interviewed there's
Jane by the way we interviewed PMS devs
and tasks in each group and we also
interviewed people from Boston India but
I won't be discussing that and I will be
discussing the tests because we didn't
get enough interviews with tests Boston
in India have their own issues related
to language and culture which are very
interesting but I'm not dealing
specifically with that today so what is
the overall finding from this study well
if we graph how the interactions are
happening as a group we have platform
and application and platform as their
tasks and application has their tasks
I'll just give a quote in order to
really that sums up the situation that
we saw we're consuming their stuff we're
not really giving them anything so
there's nothing that they really need
from us or want from us we want stuff
from them and we expect stuff from them
this quote kind of sums up really the
point that I'm making in this talk which
is that there is an asymmetric
dependency between these two teams
application yes the API the between the
platform in the application was that
negotiated was that set by the
application teams that set went from you
the interface between these two systems
I'm not exactly sure it from the
interviews I believe that there is a
negotiation because they need to figure
out what they're going to do in the next
product cycle and so platform has to
agree to do something to change the
api's in a certain way that benefits or
that application needs to do their job
the only customer platforms yeah at the
time that we studied they were the
primary customer and a new team had just
started up to become the second group
that depends on platform which would
make this in even more asymmetric
because now application is not even the
only group that depends on them yeah the
consequence of this can be explained in
another quote that sums up I guess the
effect is that I think that everyone is
aware that there's a lot of tension
between our teams at least I definitely
see it on the application side and we've
got quite a few quotes that indicate
that there are a tent that there's
tension and bad bad feelings between the
two groups so what I'm concerned with
here is how does this asymmetry between
the two groups affect what I've
mentioned before the behaviors the
perceptions any expectations so the
first finding we want to know are the
perceptions actually different between
the two teams so when I say perceptions
I mean if you focus on app p.m. how do
they perceive the interaction between
platform p.m. now that's indicated by an
arrow going into applique
pm so if we take applications pm's point
of view platform is sending behaviors to
application and if we take platform PMS
point of view application is sending
behaviors to platform p.m. we want to
know what is the what are the
characteristics and what are the
properties of those interactions and
really fundamentally are they do each
person does each group perceive this as
being different even though it's the
same interaction do they perceive the
quality of that interaction differently
that's the question we're trying to get
at so if we graph just very simply take
counts of the number of helpful and
unhelpful so the percent of behavior is
reported to be unhelpful versus on
helpful for each link for each link here
there's three links application p.m.
plat p.m. pi p.m. app dev and app dev
platinum so for each of those links
what's the percentage of helpful not
helpful from each point of view so I'll
just discuss the first I hear
application p.m. perceives seventy-three
percent of their behaviors are reported
as being unhelpful versus twenty-seven
percent are helpful and platform p.m.
for the same link sixty percent and
forty percent so the important part here
I think is the difference between the
two the slope I guess of the of the
difference between helpful not helpful
so we can see that that is steep and
that's a little less steep that's
extremely steep and that is actually in
the opposite direction so this link is
interesting these two are relatively
similar slopes so is there another way
of looking this maybe clarifies the
issue I think there is if you take what
we know as an interaction effectiveness
ratio so just simply take the number of
helpful behaviors over unhelpful
behaviors and we'll get a number
we're a number of dangers loans yeah and
our member being you know number of
people sorry yeah the number of
behaviors I think there's around 56 60
behaviors in in these two guys yeah
we're stepping back a little that's
correct interview ask them to report all
the behaviors that have happened in a
certain period of time that were helpful
or unhelpful I guess I was assuming from
your previous question that you'd said
to identify one identify an event but
not you know try to identify as many as
possible until they're they're exhausted
they've exhausted their memory of things
that are significant to them yeah so
this is just it's in effect it's a rough
measurement in qualitative work by the
way this is not usual for qualitative
work using numbers and graphs but I'm
trying to at least impart some kind of
measure of objectivity and I'm telling
you exactly how much doesn't fit into my
my point of view the argument that I'm
making asked this question and should
you or no um no this was the first time
that they've been asked yeah really for
quality of work the important part is in
the quality of the statements what's
inside the quotes but here I'm trying to
give an overall view so we can get that
through interaction effectiveness yeah
sure um is it is it typical for people
in coordination studies to see you
negative or should I as a Microsoft
employee be alarmed but good people soon
be having such for interaction okay so
the question is is this normal to have
poor interactions in in coordination
studies yeah today are they I for its
negative or is there some no defect
about these things so yeah well we know
from previous work on looking at the
effectiveness of interactions for
example in the bell study the average a
link effectiveness average was probably
around 20 point 95 so in general we get
about the same number of helpful and
unhelpful so if you're very below that
then it's cause for alarm but that is a
organization specific issue so if you
are look at these numbers in your
alarmed we can go through a process of
improvement where you would say okay
right now our average is 0 point 5 in
next year let's try to get that average
up to one and then let's get it up to
1.5 let's get for every unhelpful
behavior let's have two helpful
behaviors that could be one one way of
improving the organization but yeah
these are relatively low numbers
compared to what I've seen before but in
general the perceptions are going to
skew a little bit negative if there is a
subordinate dominant relationship
between the two people and i'll be
talking about that in a second yeah yes
Lee just mentioned this point 5 1 like
hires better hires better yeah because
more helpful yeah sorry yeah helpful /
unhelpful so yeah hire is definitely
better one is same obviously so here we
have application p.m. perceives this
interaction as being relatively negative
and it's quite a few of those behaviors
as being unhelpful platform p.m. on the
other hand perceives it a little bit
better but still just generally not
great application dab perceives the
situation is being extremely negative
but platform p.m. perceives the exact
same interaction as being quite a bit
more positive and platform death nap
Deborah just generally a pretty bad
situation here
I thickness of the line indicates it's a
rough indication the number of behaviors
so I would take yeah i would take a
platform death an app dev interaction as
with a low grain of salt because there's
not a whole lot of behaviors in that and
that's why i'm trying to be open and
honest about it by putting the link is
very small yeah we can the larger the
link is better data now the argument
that I'm making here is I'm proposing
the difference in perception is due in
part to the task asymmetry so because
applications so dependent on platform
and that dependencies task-related
platforms behaviors will severely affect
application but applications behaviors
do not severely affect platform and so
that's I believe one of the reasons at
least in part that will have a
difference in perceptions previous
research has indicated that with a
dominant and subordinate relationship
the subordinate will perceive more
negative behaviors from the dominant
person because if you're in a
subordinate style of relationship that
dominant person's behaviour will really
just generally affect you a negative
things become very more negative and so
just in general will perceive when you
have an asymmetric relationship you will
perceive more negative things so at
least this is somewhat supported by
previous literature now the next thing
we're interested in our priorities are
the priorities different or are the
behaviors of things that people actually
do are they different and and i found
the main theme here is priorities so of
all the behaviors that application
mentioned as important so either helpful
or unhelpful from platform of all those
behaviors they mentioned a lot of the
behaviors we're related to priorities
now they do or they don't prioritize our
needs so application depends on platform
to do things for them and they perceive
that platform doesn't prioritize those
needs let's see to what extent
we'll see application p.m. five percent
of all the behaviors are related to
priorities and they're helpful fifty-six
percent of all behaviors are unhelpful
and they relate to priorities
application dev very similar forty-four
percent of all their behaviors that they
mentioned we relate its priorities and
they were unhelpful yes see that the
priorities for something you were going
to speak about forehand or did it
surface to your hair so for those out
there the question is did we did we
expect to find priorities in the data no
not at all because we went in there in a
very exploratory manner and we're just
interested in what's actually happening
this emerged from the data yeah which i
believe is also a benefit of this type
of method we were try not to impose our
own view of this situation we let the
participants tell us what's important to
them in this case clearly application
thinks that priorities are a problem
I'll give some quotes because that's
what the really fun part is i'm going to
only give a few because i don't have
time but i've got so many we can discuss
discuss them later our critical
dependency was not seen as a priority by
them ten behaviors fell into that
category a quote the person in charge of
specifying the feature he was a contract
to his left for six months so it seems
like if I was going to develop a feature
that a bunch of other people rely on or
if I was a manager and I was looking at
all the people to assign to a feature I
would definitely not assign the feature
that everyone relied on to the person
who was going to leave and I picked that
because it's this particular behavior
led to a lot of very bad impacts on this
person's group for example because the
person left they had to give a work item
to platform near the end of the
iteration and it severely affected
work-life balance it is difficult to get
platform p.m. to do what we need them to
do now that's also in general related to
priorities because if obviously if
platform prioritized applications needs
they wouldn't have to bug them so much
to get them to do what they need them to
do you have to present a very strong
case and it's always difficult when you
say hey you guys you should do this we'd
make our job a lot easier it's just as a
difficult ask unless you can say well
this is how it benefits you and the
third category is a hot potato feature
this I hadn't heard of before but what
happens is platform needs sorry
application needs platform to develop a
feature X and then add Y to it so X plus
y but platform doesn't see that as an
issue they just want X they think X is
fine so application is they have to take
that feature and develop it on their own
but it's not part of their code base and
causes a lot of issues and then in the
next iteration management says okay that
really belongs in platform so in the end
it gets bounced around a number of times
throughout features and this is a
feature that just nobody wants to deal
with platform doesn't want to deal with
it an application it can't deal with it
from platform PM's point of view the one
comment that I found related to
priorities is there's a little bit of
attention to my thinking of two things
I'd like to interact more with them so
that I know the direction they're taking
so we can build the right things on the
platform on the other side is that the
best value for me or so I just focus on
the platform and the interaction we're
having is good enough so I don't know
the answer to that
so here we can see that platform has
trouble balancing priorities so this
difference in priorities I'm perceiving
or I'm sorry I'm arguing is a result of
the task asymmetry so just in general
this is a software engineering example
of a fundamental law of human perception
identified by the gestalt psychologists
attention is selective and focused and
an I argue because platform is not
dependent on application in any
significant task related way platforms
attention is focused on their own work
hence they prioritize their work highly
and do not prioritize applications work
so for the next finding we found that
expectations are different also I'll go
through an example of this too and that
will help really explain what I mean by
application so I mean by expectations so
expectation from application is I want
platform to do things for me I find this
this is a very interesting category by
the way to put our needs higher on their
priorities that's 18 behaviors to be
responsive to my emails about my
dependencies and to consume their code
before they release it to us so these
are things application wants platform to
do on the other hand platform tends to
want a plication to refrain from doing
things so don't expect us to track your
dependencies don't send too many or too
complicated requirements and don't
escalate unnecessarily so the
expectations that each group has are
different for each other it's kind of an
interesting fight did not expect to find
this actually so what we found here is
if we graph the number of expectations
of things to do an application is much
higher if we graph the expectation don't
do this then platform so platform
primarily says don't do this don't do
that effectively be a good dependency
and leave me alone so
from applications point of view they
expect platform to do things that makes
their job easier because of this
dependency I'm arguing in platform
because they're not task-related
dependent on application from platforms
point of view they expect application
not to do things they consider to be
unhelpful so it's still I think it's the
the reason for this is that the task
related interactions are asymmetric yes
first example um when you're talking
about the I guess the perception
asymmetry you divided up the platform
and application teams by roll by p.m. at
that okay but you can do that for this
one you know do you see the similar
trend for if you divide it up by the
three times yes yeah yeah well because
platform p.m. and platform dev in this
case both expect their counterpart to
still do things so the role division
doesn't really change this too much and
I wanted to simplify it for the for the
presentation yeah but yeah if if you
want to really dig into the data then
splitting it up my role would give you a
bit a bit more thinner slice of the data
a bit more information yeah it's always
better to split my role in this case I'm
simplifying
so this study found three things that
task asymmetry affects our perceptions
the task is symmetry affects our
priorities how we prioritize our work
and task asymmetry effects on our
expectations to give you an idea of why
this is important or why this finding is
significant I'll show you what we knew
before what we knew before from
literature and it's a lot of literature
says that as our interdependence II
increases so do our number of helpful
behaviors now uh I think from what I've
shown we can now see that this is
perhaps in highly inadequate way of
looking at the situation and I think
it's because the way that organizational
behavior is thought of interdependence e
before this concept they have an inner
dependency is one of reciprocal
independency where it's good behaviors
going back and forth and I think anytime
you take a look at a concept like this
from the literature and then you go into
the real world and you do some actual
real-world observation and interviews
you find that concepts like this just
don't they're just not adequate to
describe what's happening in real world
because this is not what in your
dependency is always like it could be
like this it could be like that could be
like this like that I think the only
time you'll have this is in a very
select few instances where you'd have
perfectly reciprocal and helpful
interactions and that's what they mean
by near dependency yeah a manager
accommodating seems in watering actions
try and contain from these sort of
findings I mean given that sort of in
our business the division between
platform in an app is almost inevitable
lat least for certain classes of
services or products
yeah so the question is basically I
think what do we do with it what do we
do about this when software engineering
in many cases tries to split up groups
into application platform right so in
this case you have software engineering
forces that say goods good software
architecture demands clear separation
and modular ization and follow all the
good stuff that parnis told us right and
social findings of this study show that
perhaps that's not good for the social
interactions between the teams and I'm
not sure how to balance that I think
that there's an interaction here that's
really complex and I can't give you a
definitive answer until we look at the
exact situation so i'll give you the
theory that i'm going to explain right
now it will give us a way of maybe
analyzing a specific situation to see
where that where that ideal amount of
separation in interaction would occur so
we don't often see a black screen and
presentation do it so what why is this
impressive why is this important I think
that's a really you know a reasonable
question ask ask it to myself all the
time we saw similar things happening in
Bell in their new product development we
saw similar things happening an object
mentor in their agile software
development it points to I think a
crucial and essential issue in
organizations why is this person
unhelpful towards me why do these groups
not coordinate well together and how can
we help them coordinate better this is
essentially Tom's question so I'll dive
a little deeper into this issue using a
thought experiment in building up a
theoretical model of coordination and
there's different ways to analyze this
problem we can analyze it economically
my background is my undergrad is in
economics and we could construct game
theory and do all that nice calculus
with that or we could look at it
dynamically and I'll be choosing that
attacked using Levine's field theory so
let's start with a thought experiment we
have two participants a and B now a is
task is to draw cards between one and
nine and you only have two cards of time
and drawing a card costs a dollar and
their goal is to make ten in the least
number of cards so maximize profit so we
can see that his goal set the
combination cards that will satisfy his
goal are going to be 55 4637 28 and 19
so it's a very simple game but it will
lead to very complicated results for the
mathematical inclined it's sampling with
replacement and all that fun stuff now
B's task is exactly the same as a except
a gives his cards to b and b's task is
exactly the same make 10 with two cards
except that B's cost is going to be a
function of the difference between the
two cause that a sense
so the cost per card is going to be one
dollar plus 1 dot x the difference in
age cards so for 37 the difference would
be one dollar plus one times four so
five dollars per card so you can see
what we've done here is set up an
asymmetry we set up the situation such
that a will output into B's task and B
will heavily depend on a but a does not
depend on be the theoretical foundation
I'm using is Levine's field theory and
i've added to it using other literature
and one way to look at this the way i've
chosen is using work situation it's
highly simplified and it's not exactly
falling field theory but for this
discussion it suffices a is in a work
situation and they've got five goal
regions each of those regions of
activity will satisfy his goal so he can
move into each of those regions now each
of the regions may have a valence and
the valence is positive or negative and
a valence corresponds to a force so a
positive valence is a force acting on a
towards that regional activity and a
negative valence corresponds to a force
pushing a away from that region of
activity so our question is how will a
behave given three and seven well let's
first assume that a doesn't know bees
task and that there's no cost to cards
such that every goal region will have a
positive valence with an equal force
leading aid towards any of those regions
now it gets a little more interesting
when we add cost and communication with
be because now if B communicates his
situation to what extent does be
communicated and to what extent does a
believe be want to help be out think the
bees needs are important to him so
similar situation that we saw in the
real world well if a gets communications
through whatever means so I am email
face-to-face and believes it then 55
becomes a positive region
and all the other regions become
progressively more negative because b is
told them hey 19 that's really going to
mess me up don't give me that but 55 all
right give me that so that gives a
positive valence and a corresponding
field of forces drawing a towards it
what happens when a is cost increases
when in other words in real life can I
help be out even if you wanted to so
there's a task constraint if a cost
increases say to one dollar then the
forces acting on him to stay on 37 are
going to increase because now it's going
to cost them a lot of money to try to
get to any of the other goals so those
gold regions become negative it's costly
37 becomes positive because he's already
there and it won't cost him any more
what happens if his cost increases to
five dollars while the forces
correspondingly increase because the
same each of these regions are
equivalently negative and 37 becomes
much more positive now what happens if a
is goal is to maximize the difference
between those cards so we have this
fuzzy concept in management called goal
alignment it's kind of mystical and
mysterious and this may be one way of
getting down and saying what exactly
happens when you say my group's goal
doesn't align with your groups well in
this case the goals don't align because
a is encouraged to get a 19 that because
positive all the other regions become
progressively negative and we can see
that a is going to be encouraged by his
task to do unhelpful things for be so
that's what we call task constraints and
that's how we can analyze it using field
here so what happens to be escalates to
management there's another issue we
think you know we know how this happens
in a real world through the effect it
has on people but analytically what's
happening well we get something called
an induced force so this force comes
from outside a is work situation it's
the manager knocking on his door and
saying hey come on man what are you
doing you're not really helping be out
he needs a 55 can you
you know be a sport what happens when
bees location changes so in global
software development this is very
important issue we think from software
engineering literature that location
matters and there may be a difference
between colocation versus down the
hallway versus on another floor versus
in another building etc and so on but
what's really happening to a is
perception of his own work situation
when we're collated co-located versus
not well this is one as the theory would
predict what's going to happen is this
if we're co-located there's an external
or induced force on a to move towards
helping B because b is sitting right
next to them you can look over and say
come on help a guy out now this is a lot
more powerful induced force because they
know each other they work very close to
each other then let's say for example
being just down the hallway or in a
water-cooler conversation they would
predict that the force is going to be a
little bit less to what extent depends
on the relationship obviously between
the two people but in general we can
expect of a less induced force now when
it's over email or IM the induced force
maybe even less towards the helpful
behavior region interestingly we found
from the interviews that a picture may
help for some reason one of the one of
the devs told me that having a picture
on his email help them coordinate with
the people that are sending him emails
this is a very curious thing for me
because I'd never thought of this so
what happens when you have a picture
perhaps the force gets a little bit
stronger what happens if the picture is
happy does the face matter really what
if it's a happy face what if the face is
angry will that make a difference what
if the face is not congruent with the
message of the email will that create
some kind of conflict these are
questions I think are very important and
we can analyze
and also observe and get through
interviews it obviously I think connects
very closely to the problems in global
software development and even telework
so what we set up here is that one way
interdependence II what happens if we
fix that and try to make it a
symmetrical dependency well I think
what's going to happen is an induced
force from B to the goal region is going
to be now a lot more powerful because
previously all be could do is escalate
or just really try to get aid to do what
he wanted there was no task related way
for be to get a to do what he wanted now
A's ability to do his task is going to
be affected by bees output so now in
political science terms b is holding a
much larger stick now that i think is
going to be a much more powerful force
than simply collocation because now task
when it's a task related for us it's
extremely powerful now the total result
of all of these forces with what we call
a resultant force I'll show you I'll
I'll build up a small combination here
we can see how it gets pretty
complicated fast so a nose be situation
he's communicated 37 was initially
positive because that's what a has but
now it becomes a little bit negative so
there's two valence is on 37 because b
is told a that three sevens not good for
me instead try to do a 55 so the forces
are now changing what happens when the
cost to eight increases so now there's
an additional valence on 37 and the
forces are going in different directions
this is a curious issue here we call
this conflict because now a knows that
he really should be going to 55 to help
be out but his task constraints are such
that 37 is also equally attractive to
him
so that conflict situation would happen
a lot in in real life as well what
happens at B escalates to management the
forces are are changed by the induced
force what happens if B is on the same
floor meets in the water cooler the
forces are changed even more towards 55
in the resulting force is a most of 55
so that's one way we can analytically
look at a situation has traditionally
been kind of while using words and
rather high in the sky this analytic
solution will lead to a phase space
diagram so we can analyze exactly how
purse a perceives his resulting forces
so we have a's work situations is on the
x-axis and we move back and forth we're
going to get a graph of the resultant
force on a to be helpful or unhelpful
and at any point so let's take this
point there's going to be what we call
an equivalent forces a kind of a quasi
steady state equilibrium so at this
day's work situation his resultant force
will be to be helpful and if we change
that work situation it's going to change
his resultant force going towards
helpful which words unhelpful as you get
into the middle we can see there's an
inflection point I believe that's the
I'm predicting that us because when we
get to the middle there there's going to
be a sense of imbalance in tension due
to the conflict of trying to choose
between health and unhelpful so a will
very quickly move out of that region
because there's tension and it's
uncomfortable for a so here is a an
analytical solution to the issue of will
a coordinate with be
yep let's eat asked why I shouldn't see
the dope remain on task one because a
prefers to coordinate on testing full
house you know kind of like I'm not
going to help you with this one we're
going to do what's right for me about
this test will do is very good looking
better test so when there's two tasks
there would be to work situations fray
well it could be totally separate but
they might bleed into each other because
if task a is his behavior and task a
somehow impacts task B then there will
be a force in the task B work situation
as well related to what happens and not
yeah so at any work situation is with
respect to a certain task and if they're
other tasks do impact it then that would
be represented with respect to that task
now the contributions of this I believe
it revises our current concept of
interdependence he obviously our last
concept was probably highly inadequate
to describe what's happening in a real
world I'm proposing a field theory of
coordination which hasn't been done yet
I believe this leads to a better
understanding of how of how the or
rather sorry a precise meaning for a lot
of the abstract comments that are kind
of flowing around in management I allows
us to do a careful analysis and
experimentation at to dig deeper into
how coordination really works
so why is this important for Microsoft
well the qualitative method generates
just an extraordinary number of concrete
actual behaviors that have helped enough
not helped people get their jobs done so
for each of those behaviors it's clearly
something that we could increase or
decrease each of those behaviors are
extremely concrete impractical and I
believe that's one of the main benefits
of the qualitative aspect this could
also be used as part of action research
or continuous improvement program so
that's how we would I think to address
Todd's question that's how we would very
slowly and with the at the help of the
management of the specific group that
we're studying we would be able to
institute some kind of change to perhaps
if there is a heavy asymmetry and it's
affecting the software teams then we
would go through and try to figure out
how to adjust the other forces that are
acting too maybe compensate for an
application platform asymmetry we've
published this also how to do that
theoretically it gives us a general
theory of coordination which is helpful
because for Microsoft that leads to
basically very fundamentally a better
understanding of how to structure teams
and how to set groups and organizational
goals and motivate employees and deal
with conflict and burnout essentially
and really the final thing here
essentially is that we want co-workers
to work together because of the work
situation not in spite of the work
situation
so for future work I have quite a few
things I'm interested in I will only
deal with a couple here I'm interested
very much in global software development
I believe a lot of large software
company software companies are dealing
with this issue we're looking at it in
Bell right now they're having a problem
with their outsourcing and current
results are rather inconclusive of what
to do about global software development
and I believe that this approach both
the quality of an ethnographic side as
well as the analytic side might be able
to shed some kind of light on the issues
perhaps and my second thing is that I'm
interested in or extremely large scale
software development this is what really
got me interested in studying software
in the first place where the the books
by a you know Fred Brooks and Weinberg
and then papers like curtis's that
really talk about how large software
developments get done and i have read
i've read so many books on software
project management probably you know in
the dozens but i realized that i
actually don't know how software's
really managed in the real world and
that came kind of as a shock to me
because if you read so much you should
know a little bit more about it but i
really don't know how it's actually done
so i think having a long-term
ethnographic study of how software is
actually managed might really be a
benefit I'm also interested in agile
software development and as bagel Naga
upon found about a third of Microsoft
now uses some form of agile and it's
very important to figure out how to
agile processes interact with our
current processes is that coordination
going to cause problems or is there any
sort of issue that we should be aware of
when a lot of our company moves towards
a methodology I'm also going to talk the
last part of this talk will be short so
we're almost done I'm going to talk
about an issue that i'm interested in
which is prediction through social
simulation my Master's was on social
simulation
and having recently read the work that
Eric Horvitz is doing I think that
there's some there's a real opportunity
here to take a lot of the data that we
have about software development how it's
being developed and all of the systems
that we have that hold these artifacts
and on Gina's working on bridge so this
kind of would build on feed into that
and complement that work I believe we
have I'm sorry I'm not a graphic
designer we have components of software
that are somehow linked together we know
that this is a level of this is one
level of analysis if we overlay on top
of that a social network analysis then
we have what's known as a social
technical grew ins which is being worked
on by herb slevin a lot of other of his
colleagues now when we overlay the
social network on top of the component
network we see where it matches where it
doesn't match in the theory is that if
it matches it's better I'm not exactly
sure if that's true but it's worth
looking into of course what's
interesting here is that the social
network gives us the communication
patterns but it doesn't give us what my
study showed obviously which is the
interaction effectiveness which it
believe is a third level of analysis we
can put on top now what if we had a
system that could automatically gather
and generate this to what extent it's
possible i'm not sure but i'm really
hoping that we could do something to
generate this automatically the system
would be able to without human
intervention figure out this congruence
and then ab and flow when it changes so
that now we know that a is a lot more
central a lot more as a higher boundary
spanning role than before but we know
that a's work situation is getting worse
that he's receiving a lot of unhelpful
behaviors from his colleagues and it's
affecting his work in a way that the
system can detect and say a watch out
there's something bad happening here
and if a leaves our company will be able
to see exactly how it affects our
systems and we'll know that a is
probably the last person we want to
leave our company we may also be able to
help h find d because right now he can't
we may help be fine g so in this case we
can use a system to automatically help
connect people and to let them know when
code is being updated that they should
be aware of and when I social
interactions are leading to very
unhelpful situations and hopefully we
can predict when this would happen it's
something i'd really like to look into
in the future so to sum up this talk is
showed four things one that asymmetry
has an impact on our perceptions to that
task asymmetry has an impact on our
behaviors in this case how we prioritize
a work three asymmetry has an impact on
our expectations and four we've I've
shown that we can represent a person's
work situation as a field of forces both
task forces and social forces that
combine to move him in certain helpful
or unhelpful directions so maybe our
behavior isn't entirely free will that
we're constrained and directed by the
social and task forces that are acting
on us and maybe this will help us
organize software development a little
bit better in the future thank you very
much yes card okay so um you
demonstrated that there are differences
in perceptions behaviors and
expectations from data that you gather
how do you know that it's this task
asymmetry that's causing it as opposed
to other possible things there
yeah I think yeah that's a perfectly
perfectly reasonable question asked and
its really that's a fundamental problem
of doing case study and qualitative
research is we can't rule out other
explanations what we can do is get a lot
of data suggest that this is what's
happening and we would be able to
demonstrate using a lot of data that
this is happening but we can't prove
that there's no other explanation for it
what we can do is get other data that
we'd support and triangulate so i'm
using interview methodology here but we
could also use ethnographic methodology
and we can use quantitative methods such
as software engineering metrics that
might be able to really butchers our
argument here but in terms of social
science the only way to definitively
show something is through
experimentation base is assumptions on
given that you know I'm yeah I'm using
the qualitative data as an argument yeah
so I'm demonstrating that in this case
in this particular instance this has
occurred and I can't see in other
instances what would occur of course but
we can theoretically propose that there
is a link between asymmetry in
perceptions
can the work those on gray arrows mean
influences but because it really says
negatively influences your data suggests
that asymmetry negatively influences
reception communications so it is a
symmetry the enemy or an enemy to
effective collaboration and if so what
can what can be done organizationally to
either ameliorate the effects main
cemetery or to get rid of the end
cemeteries all together so the question
is are is a symmetry just in general the
enemy and should we try to get rid of it
in all places I think the previous
literature in this you know demonstrates
that asymmetry will lead to a lot of a
lot of negative things so definitely I
think it's a negative influence because
just I mean just logically if
application depends completely on
platform but platform has no dependency
on application then naturally there
there's no way for application to
there's no stick application doesn't
have the stick you know and so yeah it's
predominantly negative in order to fix
it I think you'd have to go through
definitely a case-by-case basis and in
some cases you might not be able to get
rid of the asymmetry but there may be
social and other task related things
that we can change and maybe
analytically we could demonstrate how
that would change you then you change
those other forces that would lead us to
too helpful behaviors it doesn't
necessarily have to be this change that
will lead to a positive change
yes yeah did you have a chance to get
the different groups together and
present your these results to them and
and so and if so I mean how did they
look they have to say about it and if
not you have you think that'd be a good
idea and what do you think they might
say oh actually Andy I think has done a
lot since I left and he has been with
them a lot more right and and you've he
presented and discussed ways of making a
difference so I think he's better to
answer that question I was Chris
actually did get results to me group
itself um there were two responses one
was of course this just confirms her
intuition about how our group our groups
are behaving towards each other the
other one was we definitely have to do
something about it and the last I had
left in with them was they wanted
someone from ms are so I was basically
trying to drive change into their group
but they have to want to help themselves
and at this point they seem to let's
just say out of eight engineering
managers that I spoke to there are eight
and mr. general managers about them
seven of the eight of them were of the
opinion that they had already made
changes that they thought might help the
interactions to make them more helpful
though from what I could tell they
didn't actually change anything on um
and then one of it actually still wants
help to improve things and he's more of
a tool centric person so he's interested
in where those tools that might help
make developers or more aware of what's
going on when when they're not getting
communicated with Leonard fantasies yes
so it seems like Microsoft this is like
the very common problem with the survey
techno centric approach means seem to
take and then there's a lot of people
saying well what about the customer and
it seems like if you had a notion of a
or customer some third thing here yeah
that person can say you know I need this
change and if I don't you know this
customer becomes much more unhappy so
there's like the third force it seems
you do need to triangulate somehow haha
and we've done things like visual studio
and they have personas and I wonder of
course it's not a management thing it's
more of a culture thing really it's it's
not saying there is this customer you
know talking to the platform a nap but
actually maybe if there were you know
you can actually almost like a mediator
Zambia saying I'm going to be really
unhappy with you know without this
features but it just seems like it just
seems like this setup is just design or
correction I don't know he can use
things to minimize it but unless the
platform people search of a better view
of the customer and now they have
bourke-white Cyril into customer
happiness satisfaction and
dissatisfaction is a party it's a party
situation master yeah you can I mean
this is this is such a simplification
for the purpose of this talk that task
net at ask I has structure is not as
this this simple obviously right it's
and we could perhaps Thank You someone
right so that's right so I had a very
minor ball yeah right but I mean even
the platform by itself is not a product
so it's out the app the platform has
consoling you know so and so it seems
also like they're you know the platform
really should be caring about these
these fits right into it so I mean a
platform is dependent on the app for
success yeah oh you think so yeah on
what you're saying though isn't there
don't you really want an asymmetry in
the sense that just by the use of the
term platform you can have multiple apps
on your platform and the platform can't
spend all this time list
one app now the app only has one
platform and it does have to spend its
time listening to it and clearly the
platform needs to pay attention to the
whole set of ABS certified I but you
can't have it I mean you really want an
asymmetry and then it just can't spend
all this time we're going at each app to
the same degree that's right and maybe
that's another thing that's certain
missing here is just the the realization
of this platform group is dealing with
multiple Albuquerque yeah I mean your
point about killer app is one that's
going to get attention this kind of
signals that fact that they have to
decide who they're going to now if
they're not listened any of the apps
then you got then you clearly got a
problem how in your mishap at the time
that I studied there was a second
application had just started up just
change flat-coated wanting component to
do yeah depending on the amount of
influence that each shows in this case
platform has all the influence yeah so
one thing I think we've been talking
about here is that this is an issue in
software development just in general
that you want this platform to not
really depend on application because
that's a fundamental principle of
architecture so one way of fixing this
would maybe be to have group forces
acting on platform such that right now
platform doesn't really care about
application and they're not influenced
to care there's no forces acting on
platform to take applications requests
seriously so you would change those
forces you would make it so that
platform really depends not perhaps
task-related dependence but
performance-related dependence
management-related dependence or
communication relay dependence that
would take place that would fill in this
gap here so that for example platforms
performance review extremely depends on
the opinion of application and
applications ask deep platform do what
you need to do and and and they said no
and in that case platform is like look
your job is to help application and
you're not helping them that could be
one way of fixing does asymmetry
perception behavioral expectations lead
to bad software or lead to buggy
software software that would get
Microsoft in trouble like it's this the
ultimate thing here for Microsoft is we
sell software to people i did not get
the buyer software where are we going to
be open i should produce the software if
we keep these behaviors or is this
something we actually need to fix well
from what the data interview i haven't
presented that data here but from some
of the other interview comments the
effect that this asymmetry has is that
application can't get its features in
when it needs it to get its features in
so that obviously would affect work
items are placed very late on platforms
plate because they didn't deal with it
when they should have that effect
software so there's definitely a
software effect but there's also a human
effect that if these people aren't happy
they're going to leave and they're gonna
have a bad work-life balance and they're
going to be generally just very unhappy
and unproductive so that also would
overall effect software yeah um yep so
there's two priests are you can go ahead
these forces already in place that over
time do act on the platform what's
missing is the perception of the
platform with those forces are how
they're growing or starting to build up
yes exactly yeah that's what this that's
the exact point here is that at this
moment platform does not perceive the
forces to be in this direction exactly
yeah and it's all it should all be with
respect to platforms point of view it
doesn't matter what management says one
of the application sorry one of the
platforms and I interviewed one of the
platform debs said at a high level we do
have on our commitments to help out
application
but obviously that has not filtered down
to task related forces opportunity to
tools to increase that perception of how
those forces are acting on e-flat for
different further he's snapped oh yeah
one of I think one of the goals of hip
is to make tools that help us
communicate and to realize our effect on
others right so that could be one of the
ways yep Edwards also getting
requirements for security price
operations so it's not likely that three
ignoring the app guys that they don't
want to help those guys interesting they
have a list of different you know yeah
they're dealing with their own
constraints that's part of the capacity
issue they have their own task
constraints which draw them towards this
region yep absolutely so it's a very
complicated issue it's not just simply
the platform doesn't want to help it's
maybe platform is completely constrained
towards this direction Microsoft that
have ten dependencies like could you
still analyze it or with this kind of
methodology or does the graph just get
major plus where would take time but I
really want to do it that's really the
fun part